قال الرئيس الايراني وابراهيم رئيس ان
الضمانه امني واستقرار المنطقه يجب ان يتم
عبر دول المنطقه وقواتها واشار الرئيس
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشتركا مع رئيس الوزراء
العراقي في طيران الى ان الوجود الامريكيه
في العراق هو افغانستان لم يؤدي الى تعزيز
الامن في هذين البلدين وابقى تعبيره
ا وقوات هذه الدول ولا جدول الاجنبي في
منطقتنا والوجود الاجنبيه
وكما لم يؤدي الحضور الامريكي في
افغانستان العراق الى تعزيز الامني فيها
لن يؤدي الى استقرار الامن في مناطق
الاخرى وبدون شك انسحاب هذه القوات من هذه
المنطقه سيؤدي الى ضمان الامن فيها الامن
والاستقرار في منطقه مهمان وسنواصل
التعاون في مجال مكافحه الارهاب والجرائم
لدينا التعاون بناء في عده ملفات ونرى ان
العلاقات الحسنه بين البلدين تؤدي الى
الرقي في العلاقات الاقليميه